welcome to this
event
brought to you by the spectator and net
wealth on the subject of planning for
retirement the road to financial
security
i'm martin vandewere i'm the business
editor of the spectator
and i'm joined today
by
two
guests who are experts on all of this
charlotte ransom who is the chief
executive and founder
of net wealth welcome charlotte and
harriet baldwin
mp she represents west worcestershire in
the house of commons she is a former
fund manager herself in the city with jp
morgan in her first career she has been
a minister at the treasury economic
secretary at the treasury
when george osborne was chancellor and
lately she's a member of the treasury
select committee so harriet thank you
for joining us we um
uh announced this event
as you'll be aware as you'll see on the
screen with a nice little graphic of a
sort of small family car
laden with a large a large
safe on its roof and lots of other
luggage and a dog hanging out of the
window and it occurred to me that was a
very good image in the sense that we all
go through life we get into middle age
with a great jumble of assets and
financial commitments without
necessarily having kept our our car
serviced if i can use that metaphor all
that time and not necessarily knowing
where we're going so
uh this is an opportunity to sort of
clarify a lot of issues about retirement
planning
and to reassure you given that we
actually
um have a
quite startlingly large audience as far
as we know today some 1500 people have
signed up to listen to us today so
you're not alone if you're worried about
financial planning for your retirement
if you're
perhaps in your
50s let's say maybe 10 years from
retiring thereabouts
you don't know what to do with the
bundle of of financial assets and other
assets with all the commitments you have
in life to sort it out for the best for
your retirement we'll hope to throw some
light on that today i'm going to start
by asking charlotte to introduce herself
and just just give us the flavor of of
the net wealth philosophy just as a
starter charlotte great yeah thank you
martian and very good to be here
um i actually spent 25 years in the city
um had my first career just as harriet
did in the city and uh 20 of those years
at goldman sachs where i was a partner
for 10 years and actually it was when i
left
the financial services industry and
retired effectively at that stage where
i realized that an awful lot could be
done to help us as individuals with
personal finance and i think my biggest
problem
with the industry as it stood was that
no one was really taking modern
technology and seeing how it could help
make these really thorny issues easier
to understand clearer more transparent
and so the idea behind net wealth our
philosophy really is to deliver all the
best bits of traditional wealth
management but to use
modern technology to make it
more flexible more transparent and much
lower cost without any compromise on the
human element and by that i mean that
most of us really still have moments we
want to speak to a human advisor and
have that reassurance that we're
thinking about things the right way and
we want to know that it's a human who
are making the decisions around what to
invest in where my money will be
invested
so
when it comes to retirement those sorts
of things are absolutely critical you
know the big questions around when am i
going to retire how long do i expect to
be retired for how much money am i going
to need during retirement am i going to
pass money on to my children before i
die while i'm retired so and the way
that technology can help bring that
alive and sort of help people visualize
those different variables is incredibly
helpful and hopefully today we'll cover
some of this to sort of try and you know
pull away the that's all mystery um and
make it rather simpler for people to
think about great okay and harriet there
are obviously sort of two strands of
conversation we can pursue one is about
what can the professionals do
to help and what decisions can you make
for yourself the other is what can the
government do to make things better or
worse for you what are the key
public policy issues uh currently on
your agenda or coming up that also need
to be considered now you've gone from
being a practitioner to being
in politics just just just kick that one
around for us for a moment thank you
very much martin yes my days as a
professional investment manager along
behind me and now i think i can bring
most relevance to today's discussion by
talking from my perch on the treasury
select committee where we scrutinize the
work of the bank of england where we
scrutinize the work of the treasury
and look at the ways in which the public
policy goals that
every government seems to seek to want
to achieve are being implemented and you
know first among those and i'm sure
we'll get on to it is the bank of
england's remit in terms of keeping
inflation low
um i'm sure you'll want to talk about
you know the public policy issues around
pensions generally we've tried to uh
encourage people to save more for their
retirement through a number of different
interventions uh whether it's through
the tax system but also really
importantly through auto enrollment
which has taken the number of savers for
pensions in the uk economy up from uh 1
million up to 10 million so it's had a
huge impact in terms of future saving
probably still not saving enough but
that's been an important public policy
intervention and then obviously there's
the stuff right nearest to us in terms
of the cost of living and how dramatic
that is particularly for existing
pensioners who are on a fixed income
yeah well let's go straight in to that
because it's the most topical
uh theme we can cover today and lots of
people have already asked us questions
about it
we could say a couple of years ago
retirement planning might have looked
rather smoother than it looks today and
suddenly we're hit by
a surge
in inflation and quite a change of
financial circumstance a lot of
uncertainty in the air right now
charlotte how
how much does that change the basic
questions like when do i retire how much
do i need to retire i can
throw some more questions but just just
just start in on cost of living crisis
what does that do to
all of this i mean you're quite right
that the environment has changed really
quite dramatically
recently over the last couple of years
and and actually the truth is we've had
an unbelievably benign environment
whether inflation or growth
over the last 30 years and so we've all
got rather used to a situation where
it's been simpler to think about
how to you know
how much we're going to need in
retirement and how we're going to fund
it
at the moment we have a very difficult
inflationary backdrop as as we know um
and that is actually being coupled with
real concerns about growth and so we've
got you know central banks now talking
about needing to to raise rates quite
aggressively we're seeing china locking
down with you know further concerns
about the pandemic which is affecting
their growth we have real sort of
consumer issues in the uk as you know we
also have inflation shocks in the u.s
and all of that's contributing to a much
more difficult overall growth
environment clearly impacted as well by
higher inflation what i think is
fascinating is that the market the way
it's reacting is it's saying basically
can't imagine that the central banks can
raise rates aggressively and that's
interesting when you think that actually
the 10-year government bonds in the u.s
are only at three percent in the uk
they're at two percent in germany
they're one percent so in fact the
risk-free rate as we talk about is
remarkably low
but there's a sense that that the
economies are really going to need some
help in sustaining reasonable levels of
growth now when it comes to planning for
retirement as you say this can really
have a dramatic impact um one of the
things i was looking at is when i talked
about the tools we use to help people
understand how they might think about
what they need in order to retire i was
thinking about as you said earlier maybe
you're in your mid 50s so you're 55 you
might want to retire say it's 65
and you might want that retirement to
last until you're 90. so often people
underestimate that's the other thing how
long they need the money to last so
let's say they're looking for it to last
25 years well
if inflation were trotting along at the
sort of two percent that we've all got
used to then in fact if you were to fund
that with 800 an 800 000 pot and over
the next 10 years before you retire put
in annual amounts of say 10 000 a year
then you could expect that port to give
you roughly fifty thousand pounds income
per annum during that twenty five year
period i was talking about
if inflation's at four percent on
average
then suddenly that port reduces down by
six years so all of a sudden now at 84
the pot runs out so what can you do
about that well obviously one thing you
can do is take a lower income and in
fact if you were to change the income
requirements down from 50 000 to say
more like 35 36
that would do it
um so you can see though there's quite a
dramatic impact from a relatively what
sounds like a relatively small change in
inflation i think the thing that we have
to remember is that inflation won't stay
at these very elevated levels for a long
time and growth will also
change over time as well um and the
thing that perhaps people forget when
they start thinking about retirement is
they think about retirement as a moment
as opposed to multiple decades so
actually for this 55 year old we've just
been talking about
they are talking about from now until
they're 90. so there's a long period
during which time there will be um you
know the markets will go up and they'll
go down inflation will right now it's
high it'll come back down again and
there is
it's important to stay sort of connected
with the variables that you can change
to make sure that over that period you
are servicing you know your needs
so
simple question if we're looking at say
a three-year
surge in the cost of living but with we
believe the
uh
imf the bank of england whoever it may
be telling us that the inflation will
calm down
in due course if you had the choice to
go on working through that search period
rather than
taking retirement now
you know you enjoy your job you might
like to go on working is it sensible to
go on working through the cost of living
search
then revisit your plan secondly if you
had a choice between taking lump sum out
of your pension arrangements or a higher
income
how would you address that in terms of
the inflation
okay so so two quite different questions
um
and i would say if you are willing and
able to continue working
um if there is this sort of significant
surge in cost of living then it would
tend to make sense to continue to have
that income coming in i mean if you have
the choice and you're willing and able
why not
um so you know i think that
generally speaking people will not tend
to have that much flexibility around
when they want to retire there'll be a
moment that would trigger is a trigger
for them when you know this is this is
the point they may though for example
because we're now able to work from home
we're able to work more flexibly
actually i think this whole point of
when retirement even begins is more of a
moot point and there is more flexibility
about how it might look
um
the second question in terms of you know
taking this lump sum i mean first of all
just to be clear we all have access to
25 of our pensions tax-free
and we could take it when we retire we
can take it several years later we can
take it all in one go we can take it in
increments there's a great deal of
flexibility about what we do with that
tax free lump sum
and
i think a lot of it will have to do with
individual circumstances so at the
moment pensions remain a very useful
tool for inheritance tax planning
because the entire
uh your entire pension falls outside of
your estate from an inheritance tax
perspective
therefore if you don't need to touch
your pension because you have other
assets at your disposal then you
probably won't take the lump sum and you
will allow your pension to continue to
grow
uh you know as you at
in whatever form it's invested
um however if you have for example a
mortgage to pay off or you're thinking
about buying um you know something for
your dependents uh a house or flats or
whatever then there may well be a reason
that you decide to take out
the lump sum
and quite often we tend to advise that
taking it all at once tends to work out
economically more to be better than
taking it out in increments but it
definitely depends on individual
scenarios the reasons i say better is
partly because there are costs quite
often to
each time you take some money out so
that decision is really driven by
personal circumstances more than wider
economic i would say so i think actually
a lot of the discussion today although
we're all you know like a bit of a
rabbit in headlights in terms of this
sort of massive number that we the press
keep telling us about and it does make a
difference as we talked about i think
actually it will still boil down to
really quite personal choices and
personal situations
yes harriet
i read
i think i read or heard that all the all
the cabinet members had been told to go
away and come back with one idea each to
ease the cost of living crisis but
particularly for people on the cusp of
retirement
actually what can the government do
anything very much
at the moment they can't really bring
fuel bills down what else could they do
well two public policy things um you
know we've tried to strengthen the sort
of foundation of people's retirement
which is the state pension and we've
tried to make that better over the years
and we got confirmation recently in the
treasury select committee from the
chancellor that he would apply the
triple lock again and that would be to
september's inflation and currently um
what's expected about then is around 7.4
so the state pension he has confirmed
will go up by 7.4
so i think that's one of the sort of
foundation blocks for people's
retirement planning which is important
um but charlotte um you know made me
think about uh you know some of the
other public policy issues around uh
pensions and it i'm stressed this is not
something that the current government
would ever think about but this 25
tax-free lump sum it is a huge
incentive for people to to to save into
a pension and it's not impossible that
future chancellors you know might look
at the whole way in which uh pension
taxation uh incentivize pension saving
and they might make future changes to it
so that would be another factor to to
take into account i think if you're
looking at your retirement planning in
the whole um you mention the cost of
living energy prices and of course they
are set in world markets the chancellor
has announced some very significant uh
sized support something like 9 billion
pounds worth of assistance to people um
often in the form of a cash grant if
you're in a
council tax a to d um but also of course
five pence off the cost of fuel which um
uh you know is not cheap
to do okay well we're not in a party
political broadcast
too much of that but there's also i
think there's an issue around the the
total size of the pension pot and the
cap on that isn't there is that am i
right that that the present chancellor
has capped that and in these
circumstances of inflation
people of sort of higher income might
well feel they'd like to have a bigger
pension pot but they can't is it just
well yes so you're talking about the
lifetime allowance um in 2006 there was
this concept of the total amount that
you can build into your pension would be
capped and at its height it was 1.8
million and then over time that cap has
come down and now it's just over a
million pounds and although a million
pounds sounds like a lot actually with a
lifetime of saving
um you could easily expect to be at a
million pounds um above that number
you are taxed at a penal rate of 55
so there's a lot of fixation around this
55 number
i would say that actually um there are
various things to think about in the
context of this of this saving into your
pension and why it can still make sense
um
first of all
that you know there is um a significant
pool of money that is tax-free as we
talked about um you know you'll be taxed
at your marginal rate when you draw from
it and it is only the amount over and
above the cap that you pay this higher
rate on but that's you know as and when
and if you draw from it um so
largely speaking as we said we would
recommend to people that they do think
about if they're going to tap into their
pension that they because as we said
otherwise you might keep it as an
inheritance tax planning tool but if
you're going to tap into it take that
tax-free lump sum
in doing so you're able to do what you
want with that which if you don't have
something necessarily planned for it you
can put it into isis which are obviously
tax efficient and you can even put it
into a taxable account but still make
use of dividend and capital gains tax
allowances that everyone has every year
but with the remainder so let's say
we're you know we have a million pound
pension and we're worried about that
lifetime allowance and going through it
the remainder therefore is a smaller
amount 750 000 pounds left on which to
be able to earn those returns that may
take you above the lifetime allowance
but not by that much
and i i think really the point is that
people must and should save into their
pensions to make sure they get to the
cap at least and then
probably in truth it'll be a relatively
marginal amount that they're thinking
about over and above that on which they
pay the higher rate i mean is that is
there some politics in that harriet in
the sense that you know a million pounds
looks like a big number but it isn't
that's what charlotte really is saying
we say we're talking about
how to secure for yourself an income of
35 to 40 000 pounds for the rest of your
life but to do that you need 800 a
million and so on these are not as big
numbers as they look but in
presentational terms that's an easy win
to put a put a cap on is that a is that
a superficial view
you know from the a public policy point
of view actually what we really want to
achieve is for the vast majority of the
population who never come anywhere near
a million pounds in terms of pension
savings to save more and to have a more
secure retirement so that will be the
public policy sort of central um
objective but i think uh where we have
found this policy cuts across uh in
terms of the public sector is in some of
the very highly paid people in the
public sector who've got these uh you
know rare things these days these
defined benefit pension schemes and are
often you know retiring earlier
as a result
particularly it's been a political issue
for um you know hospital consultants and
people who are very senior in the nhs
because obviously we all want to have as
many doctors and nurses as possible in
the nhs so that's been an issue where
i've noticed that chancellor's had to do
some tweaking around the edges and we
can't tell whether the civil servants
have retired or not because they're all
working from home
right despite despite mr reese efforts
to get them back yeah um yes you say you
say of course vast majority of people
would never get to these kind of six
seven figure saving spots but of course
a very large number of people own a
property which towards the end of their
life is probably
maybe unmortgaged or with a
small residual mortgage on it and so and
that leads us towards a sort of general
view of
the whole asset portfolio
really um
charlotte talk a little bit about
how people should think of that as
between
the physical property they own the
financial assets could you can you are
there inflation-proof investments they
should be rushing to buy right now
if you have a big house is downsizing
the obvious thing to do to get your
asset portfolio in line with your
you know your aspirations for the rest
of your life as it were
um
very interesting question i mean the
vast majority of our clients
have substantial holdings in property
largely because like so many people
property has just gone up so much over
the last couple of decades that whether
you plan to or not it is a significant
part of one's overall wealth um even
more true if if over time you've built
rent
up a rental uh property portfolio as
well
um
over and above that
we strongly recommend that people have
um investment portfolios that are
globally diversified so that they are
earning investment returns as well as
thinking about this you know chunk of
value that's sitting in property
property is often considered to be a
great sort of hedge against inflation
but
you know i think it sort of depends a
bit what type of inflation are you
talking about so you know inflation
that's led just by growth uh is can be a
good thing and can help property prices
but inflation that is partly driven by a
series of crises which is what we're
living through right now is not
necessarily going to be good for
inflation for property i mean actually
so far the property market has held up
but i think there are concerns around
just where demand is going to go at this
stage given you know all of the
different costs that we're having to
factor into daily living now
so
um i think you have to be very
thoughtful about the makeup of your
retirement portfolio because of course
one thing about property is that it's
illiquid
it's high friction costs so it's quite
expensive to get in and out of
and it's not going to throw off cash
flows unless it's a buy to let type of
property because you're you're living in
it your question as to whether you
should downsize i think is very
interesting because right now and harris
i know we'll have a view on this um
right now it's capital gains free if
it's your primary residence and i think
for many of us you would feel pretty
mortified if you are living in a six
bedroom house and there's whatever four
bedroom house there's only two of you
left now say
you don't downsize and then at some
stage there's a change to taxation and
you end up paying 28 or somewhere
between 18 and 28
on your primary residence that
previously all of those gains were
tax-free so i think you want to think
about your property in that context i
think then you really want to have
investment assets that are diversified
so that now the difference being
they tend to be liquid therefore you can
get in and out relatively easily they
throw off returns and you can customize
cash flows the way that you can't
necessarily from your property and and
then at a sort of at the other end of
the extreme there may be
other sort of fun things that you enjoy
investing in you know there's lots of
chat about crypto for example these days
that's not something i would necessarily
recommend but people will have
um things they enjoy buying and
investing in that you know may just add
to that overall portfolio that they hold
let's come back to those wider asset
choices let's just stick with property
for a second so
suppose i decide
on downsizing from my family-sized house
to something that
would suit a retired couple with
occasional guests that releases some
cash clearly
one choice for that cash would be a buy
to let property so two questions for
uh our politician panelist does it well
one is is there any risk that
the tax advantage of your you know
no capital gains tax on your principal
home is that at risk in any way secondly
um the government doesn't take a
particularly friendly view of the buy to
let market is that going to get tougher
or might it get easier
going forward yeah great great questions
there i mean i think of politics in
terms of you know the electric third
rail in politics i would have thought
that taxing the capital gain on your
primary residence would be the kind of
electric third rail that no politician
would ever go and near i i would hope
but um you know certainly it's um
you know wise of of charlotte to
highlight it um because you know every
budget when the chancellor stands at the
dispatch box you know only he knows or
so far it's always been he um what what
they're going to announce and uh i think
that on the second question around you
know buy to let i remember from my old
days as an investment manager that
there's really only one free lunch in
investing and that's diversification
isn't it not putting all your eggs into
the same basket and so there's
wisdom in what charlotte was saying
about a broadly diversified global
portfolio of different things rather
than all being uk property which has
done well there's no question about it
um and then buy to that also raises
political issues because you get parts
of the country where they have a huge
number of second home owners and i'm
thinking of you know the lake district
of cornwall and so on um where
you know i hear my colleagues who
represent those parts of the world
raising this as a huge issue for their
local population who find they can't get
on the housing ladder and all
politicians want everyone to be able to
get on the housing ladder and work
towards owning their own home that's
a very common ground in politics so i
think there's probably much greater risk
in terms of change around the buy to let
taxation than there might be around the
primary residence
and quite understandably the first time
buyer
and the access to the housing ladder
is a more important political issue than
they the rights or benefits accruing to
buy to let investors that's
understandable isn't it yeah maybe just
one thing to add actually to the point
about buy to let's because it is a very
frequent question from a certain
demographic as to as you say do i
downsize and then do i take that extra
cash and buy a buy to let
um
instead of often
putting more into my pension or adding
to my isis and actually we do this break
even analysis all the time and for the
tax wrappers the tax enhanced investment
products
it is
easily makes more sense to be invested
in them and add your pensions add to
isis assuming a sort of you know
generally positive growth of sort of
four or five percent per annum
versus buy to let and even in a taxable
portfolio so a general investment
account actually the break-even is about
10 years so in other words you need to
buy that
house or flat own it for 10 years get
the income and it's only at that point
beyond that assuming everything else
stays stable that you are better off
having the buy to let because of the the
as hard saying the gradual changes to
make that a somewhat less attractive
investment vehicles so i think it's a
really important thing for people to
understand because we have this
i think we can't help ourselves we have
this feeling that property is somehow i
can touch it i can feel it i can live in
it if i want to and it somehow feels
safer and possibly better because it's
better to understand easier to
understand and it doesn't get marked to
market every day so you don't get those
sort of worries when the markets fall
yeah but again the arithmetic needs to
need to work yeah i just want to say
it's a great pleasure that so many
people have have logged on to watches
you are very welcome to to ask questions
and we'll devote the last 20 minutes or
so of the the show to the questions that
have come in so by all means do do put
them into the the chat box and i will
take some of your questions as soon as i
can but let's meanwhile
go a little further into this sort of
asset allocation
question people a lot of people asked us
in the preliminary questions
what's is there a right allocation
between
uk based assets
equities guilds and so on and
global assets emerging market assets i'm
often surprised i mean when i look at my
own
sort of managed portfolio of savings but
also i sit on a couple of investment
committees i'm often surprised how
little is invested in the uk in those
kind of funds how do you analyze that
for a retiree who's basically going to
live in this country it's different if
if i was going to go and live in a
little flat in the south of spain or
something i might need a different
currency base but if i'm basically a uk
retiree
wanting a secure income why do i need a
load of you know overseas
investments in my portfolio um it really
comes down to this point of
diversification that harriet was raising
um and to give you a sense so for a 60
40 portfolio which i would consider to
be pretty classic for a retiree meaning
60 in the equity market 40 in fixed
income
um
of that overall exposure in the equity
markets right now at net wealth our
portfolio would be roughly 20 u.s 20 uk
10 asia 10 emerging markets 5 europe and
some commodities and gold now what i
would stress though is that the currency
exposure
doesn't line up with that so it's not
that there's only 20 sterling exposure
20 dollar exposure because that is where
i think you have to be very careful as
an investor if you are british living in
england main
liabilities in pound sterling you don't
want significant quantities of foreign
exchange exposure and you might want
somebody else to the extent that is
foreign exchange exposure to be managing
that for you so for the 60 40 portfolio
i just described it would actually have
about 60 sterling exposure and then 40
percent we would manage the foreign
exchange exposure which we believe to be
beneficial to the uk investor and now
i'll give you a reason
sort of current reason why that might be
the case as you've probably seen
sterling has taken a bit of the
battering recently for lots of reasons
the u.s dollar has done very well and
then just very interestingly as this
debate around global growth has sort of
quickened and and and the volume has
gone up the japanese yen has started to
do very well again and again that is a
typical sort of safe haven for people to
be in so
as an individual investor i would be
unlikely to rush out and buy japanese
yen i want someone doing that for me so
that i know that i've got the right sort
of currency mix as well as the right
sort of
country mix if you like that we were
just discussing
and a lot of people don't really spot
the fact that many
of the ftse 100 blue chip companies
which you might think of as uk assets
are in fact
global businesses whose business is much
more affected by the level of the dollar
as especially
so you have to sort of be able to see
through that or your advisor needs to
make it very transparent to you so that
takes me to another question which is
is it
better easier
better for the customer to see a
portfolio of individual stocks or is it
just much more sophisticated
to to buy into
you know fun products and fun to fund
products and and
can these computer-generated portfolios
which may be difficult to understand but
on the other hand they are a more subtle
form of investment vehicle altogether
and if you just pick 10 or 20 stocks
you're taking a different
set of risks if you follow my question
how how do you analyze that one
well i think um concentrated stock
portfolios which is you know typically
if you're talking about 10 stocks that
would be considered really quite
concentrated
and
that is you know there are many
professionals who have spent an entire
career trying to do that well and have
very often failed
so as a rule
active managers have tended to be unable
to outperform
net of their fees
whatever is the benchmark they're trying
to outperform now there are obviously um
luckily some groups that for whom that's
not true so take scottish mortgage
trusts for example or take fundsments
these are groups that have done well
that are concentrated stock pickers
but take scottish mortgage trust and
actually it is half the value today that
it was last november
so
there are
as you would expect much more
significant swings when you take
concentrated bets which is why one of
the things we absolutely advocate is
that for
the core of your holdings
what i would suggest is that people go
for what i call sleep well returns
so trying to drive returns that are
inflation plus a bit
or a bit more depending on how much risk
you want that match up with your overall
financial goals
and then the concentrated funds the ones
that are you know maybe you want to
invest in yourself or you know you there
are managers whom you you like and you
trust
put some of your money in that where you
might get
ginormous returns or you might get you
know relatively ginormous losses but on
a relatively small proportion of your
overall wealth and and i think that
lines up quite well versus you know the
property
the more sort of flexible globally
diversified low-cost core of your
investments and then potentially that
you know the concentrated portfolio as
well but i think people need to
understand that it is much more risky
buying into those very concentrated
portfolios yes scottish mortgage trust
for example
actually is a picker of tech stocks a
lot of u.s tech stocks that's that's yes
and they've done brilliantly well for us
nothing has to do with scotland or
mortgages
but it has been great and then took a
great dive didn't it and and fun smith
depends on
the how much you how much faith you
would have in an individual fund manager
from a supervisory
view treasury select committee view of
the industry now the wealth management
industry and so on do you do you have
big worries that there's too much slick
salesmanship too much um complexity
and we the problem of too many hidden
fees has been a little bit unraveled
hasn't it but what are your worries as
an overseer yeah i think um you know you
have touched on a really uh good topic
there martin which is uh the fees that
the industry charges often for index
like investing is one of my pet
peeves and bug bears and i do think that
um there is other obviously our it's a
great strength in the united kingdom
we've got some fantastic active
investment managers located in the uk
and people can take advantage of them
but it is really a full-time job
figuring out who they are and keeping on
top of what they're doing and similarly
if you're doing your own personal
portfolio you're not going to have that
edge that some of the
the professionals have in terms of
access to um the the investor meetings
and so on so i think that for the
ordinary investor really a diversified
uh broadly invested group of of funds
ones that have low fees for me
you know is something that from a policy
point of view is something we should
incentivize i think that the fees that
can be charged for you know very very
average products when you consider how
low rates of return are you know
actually one of the most sensible things
you can do as a as a retail investor is
look for someone who's not going to
charge you a huge amount for your
portfolio yeah
can i add to that because as you know
well i have a very very strong view on
this and it's really why i started net
wealth um because
fees can make such a colossal difference
i mean we actually had a client who came
in and was specifically talking about
his retirement
and he is moving his um reasonably
significant pension from somewhere else
to us and we showed him that he in his
case would be saving one percent per
annum in fees
and the difference to his pension port
was that he was able to earn an
additional seven years on a 30-year
retirement port so just as a proportion
if you think 23 years versus 30
that you paying an extra 1 in fees per
annum results in that sort of difference
to your retirement is absolutely
mind-blowing and i think
it is something which is actually very
difficult often for people to
actually know how much they're paying so
harriet mentioned fees we're all talking
about fees but what are these fees you
know what are you even meant to ask
and
actually what happened is the um the
regulator had to impose a new law
that is called mifid2
that requires a wealth manager now to
put into your report what their actual
fees are broken down by not just their
management fee but how much of the funds
that they're managing underneath that
what are the transaction costs what are
the advice fees and what is therefore
the total cost and even with that so
first of all it's slightly remarkable
that you have to have a new law to say
to people you should really tell them
how much you're charging
outrageous
and second of all i've talked to endless
people who can't actually get even to
the page where that now is meant to be
spelled out and when it is spelled out
it's not spelled out in a way which is
necessarily that easy to understand so
i would say
the minimum that we see people save when
they move to net wealth is one percent
per annum but we found people who are
saving two percent per annum and it is
absolutely critical to the difference it
makes to retirement planning and to
financial futures
um that takes me to well one of the
questions that have come in from the
audience roger has asked us a question
finding a trusted advisor to provide
just advice is hard
rather than um
[Music]
paying the
set fee on assets under management so
what use is an ifa
is an ifa someone you should consult at
the beginning of your retirement
planning and when you've got it in place
you don't need to pay
separately for that advice
you need products as well as advice
where where does the ifa come in how do
you know you've got a good one
well that is a very interesting question
uh because this is an unbelievably
fragmented industry meaning there are
huge numbers of ifas across britain
and
personal finance is a topic which lots
of people find quite difficult to get to
grips with and so
they end up getting themselves into a
situation sometimes where they think
they've got a friend
who is helping advise them you know with
what they need to do but that friend is
actually taking quite a lot of money off
the table for themselves so
um
when you assess whether or not this is
the type of person you want to work with
i think you need first of all to be sure
are they asking the right questions in
terms of really trying to understand
what you're trying to achieve what are
your financial goals they're not trying
to sell you product or not even indeed
their service but they're listening to
what it is you want and they are
completely clear when you ask them
how their costs work which lots if you
ever feel someone isn't being clear
they're almost definitely not and there
will be other things going on
um
the question about advice though is a
very interesting one because
i think that we will all probably have
moments in our life when advice is
necessary so retirement is a classic one
you know as you run up to retirement or
possibly you've just started
it's a good time to have a sort of mark
to market and say okay am i in a in a
good position now to
think about retiring have i got what i
need and so on
there may be other moments it might be a
divorce it might be
an inheritance it might be another sort
of liquidity event
it might be that you want to start
thinking about giving money to your
adult children
and you want
somebody to help you think through have
i got enough for my retirement and how
much can i give to my children and in
what sort of periods
um so
the way that net wealth charges for
advice actually is if people want to
take advice annually they can in which
case we charge point two of a percent
but actually more people
um take it one off so you pay by the
hour and actually i i really think that
generally speaking people need that
choice because you will have people who
feel comforted by annual advice but for
most of us you don't necessarily need it
every year and there are these one-off
moments when it's super helpful
and actually i think that is where the
financial services industry does come
into its own that actually the real
value you can get is with good advice
because if you get good advice it will
really help you think about
in your retirement you know how best to
save for what you're trying to do and
actually importantly as well
where to draw from which pots to draw
from in the most tax-efficient way so
there's lots to be said for advice but
it is generally speaking overcharged for
and
um
you know
your view on the ifa sector or where
else to go for good advice i i think you
know when i was economic secretary i did
something called the financial advice
market review to see where the big uh
problems and gaps were from a public
policy point of view and one of the
things that we've put a lot of emphasis
on since then has been
the free access to guidance so not
advice
called pension wise which is out there
in which anyone can consult and get an
appointment free of charge for that
guidance now one of the things that you
may get as a result of that guidance is
now would be a good time to go and see a
financial advisor and then you know
obviously i think uh you want to look at
the range of different uh ways in which
the internet is disrupting uh this this
space as well as
who might be good locally in word of
mouth so um i think i wouldn't add
anything to what charlotte uh has said
except that i would say to uh people
listening that if you think you want to
try
to get some guidance then pension wise
is the one that the government
provides and i think has had some good
feedback but not enough people are using
it
and we might say that the wise friend
you need at certain points decisions
about inheritance gifts and so on may
not be an ifa it may be the family
solicitor
the wise old family friend and so on
let's take it let's take a couple more
questions from the
audience uh
so
uh here's a here's a
rather technical one
um
charlotte what role could equity release
play in retirement planning mark asks is
this one equity release yes um i mean
this is where you're able to take the
value of your property and to you know
um basically
earn
a a pot of money based on the value of
your house that then on in the event
that you die the
the property value will be paid back to
the person that you've effectively
borrowed from
um
we
tend to see relatively little of it
among our clients um so we don't spend a
lot of time advising on it i think that
it's one of those tools which is
good to know is available um i think it
is very important though whenever you're
borrowing money um to think quite hard
about what a you know what actually what
is the charge effectively what do you
what is it costing you because it's all
very well said well once i die i don't
have to worry about it but it may well
be your children's problem or you know
so
i'm
a little bit skeptical um having said
that i can certainly see in some
people's cases it it it's the right
thing to do it it
could i mean this may be an unfair thing
to say harry tell me about right it's
the sort of device that could smack of
miss selling or hard selling one
imagines the equity release
salesman sort of going from door to door
slightly
yeah slightly uncomfortable and also as
a constituency mp you know i have had
some horror stories come through my case
work so i would
ask people to think long and hard and
also ask questions about what interest
rate they would be paying and
compounding at
when they look at equity release
something to be very careful about yeah
i mean generally speaking anything that
sounds too good to be true
is too good to be true and anything that
is suggesting it can return multiples of
the risk-free rate is by definition
going to have deep embedded risk in it
so you know we've seen these mis-selling
problems in the past um and i'm sure
there will be you know hopefully fewer
but nevertheless the same sorts of
problems in the future and it's just
worth remembering you know harriet
mentioned this notion of a free lunch
and there being no free lunch bar
diversification
you know i would say it kind of goes
back to those things of what are the
things you can control versus what are
the things you can't control and really
trying to focus on those bits that you
can so don't sit with piles of cash do
make sure you know exactly how much
you're paying someone in fees and
whether it's the right thing to do do be
diversified you know there are things
that are within our control
what's what's outside is you know when
am i going to die uh are the markets
going to go up or down you know where's
inflation going um and those are more
things that you can model for rather
than control yeah
one more
rather technical one this is from julian
can charlotte comment on salary
sacrifice for additional voluntary
contributions for those on modest
salaries
well actually i think this might be one
for harriet more than for me well i
would say that one of the biggest tax
breaks you have in this country is that
that allows you to save for your pension
and basically you're saying forfeit the
salary now because you will have a
stronger salary when you retire and i
think that's the behavior that it's
intended to drive and i would anyone who
can afford to uh put more into their
pension i would always suggest that they
put more into their pension yeah
good yeah good
um a question from david if you have
accumulated pensions from different
workplaces is it best to consolidate
them or leave them separate that now
there are sellers of that service that
advertise quite heavily yes is it a good
thing well um
yes is my answer um and the reason for
that is it's very interesting
it's more and more common for people to
have now multiple places of work so you
know several generations ago someone
might have stayed in one place for life
now now that's no longer the case and so
lots of people will have two three four
maybe more pension pots
and each one of those individual pots
might not be that big in and of itself
but in total they amount to quite a lot
and what happens when you have different
pots in different places you lose sight
of what are they invested in how much am
i paying to have them invested have i
made any decisions about do i like what
they're invested in and you can even
lose the pension itself which i think is
also a problem of people not even
knowing where it is so
the other
reason why it tends to be the case that
people have these disparate pensions is
because the industry meaning the
financial services industry has tended
to make it quite difficult to move it
so you may need to know passwords you
may need to have information you don't
feel you can easily get hold of
and so one of the things we we do and
and there are others who try to do this
as well is if someone comes to us and
says okay we're here i've got these four
different pensions from this group or
these groups
these are my policy numbers that's all
we need to know and the team actually
will then go and sort of retrieve them
all if you like and and put them into
one place and the reason the last thing
i'll say about the reason why it matters
so much
is because
as i said at the outset
retirement is a long-term thing
so if you don't have your eye on where's
it invested how much are you paying and
so on
you know i went back to this
this example of people paying at least
one percent more than they should in
fees that's not just for a year that
might be for 30 years
and as a rule of thumb by the way for
every 10 years you overpay one percent
that costs 14 percent of your capital so
100 000 pounds that's 14 000 you're
giving away so
it actually matters a lot to be i think
to bring this together and really make
sure you're making the most of that
value so
we shouldn't confuse
say that pension consolidation and the
mechanisms for that are now well
recognized
and
you're saying that has a clear advantage
and we shouldn't confuse that with the
previous era of mis-selling of personal
pensions when people sometimes put their
their sort of
their pension pot from their employer
into a personal pension and they were
they were ripped off basically very very
often yeah well so now sips
self-invested personal pensions are the
absolute norm and and a sip is just a
wrapper yeah you know so you can take
your sip and do with it what you want it
doesn't sort of belong to a specific
group
and martin if i may on this again from a
public policy point of view um we've
been passing legislation that enables
pensions dashboards so just as people
have got used to
open banking where you can see more than
one bank account with your existing bank
pensions dashboards will allow you to
look across all your different pensions
because in fact i was startled to learn
that the average person in the uk now
will work for 11 different employers in
their
lifetime so i'm going to
fire a question at you harriet we've
obviously been talking about
um
retirement planning for largely for
middle-class folk who are not too badly
off here but shmuel asked us what's your
solution to financial security for
retired people from low
socioeconomic groups so let you know
just for a moment let's address people
who haven't got the half million pot or
much much smaller they might own
their house
that may be their only substantial asset
where would where do you start
well i think again go back to the state
pension and the strengthening that we've
put in place with the state pension i
know that um over the three year time
horizon it will have been triple locked
and it will have protected against these
rises in inflation uh that we've seen
for people who are relying on that basic
state pension the other thing i would
really like to get out as a very strong
message is there are so many people in
this country i think it's 850 000 people
on low incomes who are entitled to
pension credit who do not actually
register for pension credit so there's
money just sitting there for them that
they're not asking for so i would
recommend uh people do a benefits check
to see if there are benefits they could
be accessing um obviously as you get
older you um
or get the the money in terms of your
your heating allowance that's very
important um but also in your local
authority they may have a discretionary
fund that can help you that is perhaps
administered in as in my area by the
citizens advice so there are a range of
different schemes that do help people on
low incomes but my central message would
be about making sure you're claiming
that pension credit you're entitled to
and
should you go to the citizens advice
bureau should should your constituent
come to your surgery to get the details
either would be fine and there are some
quite good uh benefit checkers on the on
the dwp website like turn to us and
things like that which will um allow you
to put in your details and we'll give
you some some signposting
yeah
i'm sure it's all there online somewhere
oh i know i know well then
go and see your friendly local mp yeah
yeah sitting in front of them yeah yeah
we've got we've got six or seven minutes
left we'll do one or two more quick
questions so charlotte any comment david
asks on splitting money with one spouse
assuming you're staying married yes yeah
um
so so actually that's a very good
question because one of the things we've
talked a little bit about today is that
there are
definite tax allowances that we should
all be taking advantage of so
pensions
isis
the two probably most important ones and
often we find that people haven't
thought that if their spouse hasn't
maxed out on those areas that they
should contribute into them as well so
assuming you're intending to to remain
married which is you know always always
positive um it is definitely worth
making sure that if you have a
non-working spouse or somebody who
stopped working you know for whatever
reason that that you are helping max out
on their pension
same to max out on their ices
um and then i would say the other thing
to think about is even if you want to
keep your finances separate which is
some what some couples choose to do and
is completely understandable it is worth
thinking about if you're going to have
financial advice or you're going to have
your money managed by somebody to think
about that
together even though you may remain two
independent clients because you will you
know certainly in our case um we have
something called the net wealth network
and you build economies of scale across
a family or across actually friends if
you want which allows you then to all
benefit from lower fees so i you know i
think um the sort of the spousal
awareness of how you can
make make the most of the family unit is
a very important thing to think about
and really important to highlight that
to get your full state pension you need
those 30 years of stamp effectively and
that the years that you take out if you
do for child care can be um added back
in in and that's it's really important
for women but who pretend to be um
predominantly people who do this um that
they make sure that they've accrued all
those years so that they get the full
state pension when they retire
do you have any sort of rule of thumb
about when people should pass assets to
their children other than
on death as it were or is that entirely
a matter of personal circumstances and
family circumstances um
it has a lot to do with family
circumstances but the one cardinal rule
is first of all work out how much you
need
so the worst possible situation is where
you have passed money on to your
children and you have misjudged how much
you're going to need the last thing you
want is to be asking them for it back so
the first thing is to work out how much
you need and and for example with
today's topic to do that in the context
of what if inflation does this what if
growth does that what if i live five
years longer than i'm expecting
think about those what ifs work out how
much you need and then i think there's a
lot to be said for starting to think
about passing money on before you die
partly you get the enjoyment of seeing
you know let's say your young adult
children now have a nicer place to live
or you know they're able to
get them out of your house educate your
grandchildren you know whatever it might
be
and from an inheritance tax planning
perspective it starts the seven year
clock ticking as well so there are you
know there are reasons why it's quite
nice to start that giving before you
know before you die and then having it
uh on death
and and if you have a little spare catch
a quick last question really and the
the things you want might think of as
more speculative or more fun the crypto
gold bars fine wine
old masters paintings those kind of
things do they come into your
spectrum of you know advice or do you
say do that if you like but that's not
okay well i'm going to give you a very
well win tour of what i call the three
pot theory okay okay so we all have
three people
so we all roughly speaking he has three
pots pot one liquid stuff cash comes in
salary rental income dividends whatever
out of that all the fun stuff you like
to do restaurants theater living more
than used to
right now
port three is what i call the it's
illiquid port it's got your house in it
um it might have the fundsmiths or the
sort of fund managers we were talking
about and it might have
things like crypto it might have fine
wine vintage cars whatever so i
sometimes call it the passion pot
and as investors
that's the port we actually quite enjoy
port two the port two in the middle is
where you drive you know core sleep well
returns and that's where a group like
net wealth comes in doing the bits you
don't enjoy as much but making sure you
have that in a low cost flexible format
and then actually you can get flows that
go from two into one if you need to top
up your cash or from two into three if
you find another passion so if you're
dead set on crypto you could do a little
bit in your passion pot but i definitely
wouldn't make it a core part of your
overall investing
all right do you want to tell us what's
in your passion pot
[Laughter]
oh dear well
or give us any other final 30 seconds
my husband collects railway memorabilia
so he's the world leading expert on the
flying scotsman which has its centenary
next year there we are so a very last
word for a few seconds charlotte if
you'd like to
i i think my parting words to um to your
long-suffering audience is listen to an
hour of us telling everyone how how
difficult it all is is to go back to
this concept of control the
controllables and if you do that you
will end up feeling a lot more secure
about your retirement yeah
so there we are work work out what you
need by way of income work out how you
can make that last the rest of your life
and sleep well i think that's our advice
anyway it's been a pleasure for me to
talk to harriet and charlotte this
morning i hope you have gained some
useful information from it and i hope
you'll all join us again when we do this
next time so thank you very much indeed
thank you for being with us and good
afternoon thank you goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you